raphaël Thelma is on a mission to stop
food waste his company salvages food
that is otherwise destined for the
garbage like these drinks that are past
their sell-by date they come from Metro
Germany's biggest cash-and-carry chain
and currently Raphael's biggest supplier
[Music]
and Oh fantastic for years I only
managed to save small amounts of food
and drink and I was saving pallets full
all the time and putting them back into
circulation making customers happy is a
great reward
Raphael sells the drinks in his own shop
he pays less than 10% of the original
price for them manufacturers only
guarantee their products are fit for
consumption up to they use by date after
that they usually get thrown away
Raphael also rescues reject fruit and
vege we didn't learn about this at
school or university I first saw a video
about it in 2009 that's when I became a
dumpster diver but I also thought we
have to find a large-scale solution his
startup is based in Berlin with a small
office that's sponsored by the European
Union as part of a funding program they
gathered their seed capital online
through small investors and they raised
a total of 100,000 euros but now they
need to find new suppliers and convince
them of their concept often they're on
the board at once they just say wow
finally someone's doing it dealing with
all this reject food they didn't know
what to do with it before if there are
concerns they're usually wondering if
it's actually legal to sell food that's
past its use-by date in Germany it's no
problem at all as long as you do sample
tests to make sure the food or drink is
still okay to consume
and if it is past the date you have to
tell the customers in the shop but
that's up Colossians in Finn's er
pillows in they hope to attract
customers with bargain prices the sample
checks are a legal requirement to make
sure people won't get an upset stomach
but if everything is okay they're free
to sell it via vomit surplus we at
surplus want to rescue food and make it
mainstream so all consumers and also
retailers and restaurants know where
they can get it that's why we said we'll
open a shop and launch a delivery
service and later we'll create an online
marketplace where suppliers and
consumers can find each other we want to
bring large quantities of food back into
circulation
but what are the customers say I think
the idea of saving food is great because
like many others in Germany I waste a
lot too much and you can save money
there too
that's really good and come on mother do
you worry that it's best the use by date
just use your common sense if I open it
and it's blue and green I don't eat it
what concept is the two opposing ideas
really inspiring
unfortunately the selection is a bit
disappointing but I hope in a week or
two that will sort itself out
Raphael only opened the shop a few days
ago the startup is allowed to use the
property rent-free but only until the
end of the year so that pressures on to
turn his passion into profits
[Music]